では ではよろしくお願いします
Asata
ṃ bhāvanam iccheyya purekhāraṃ ca bhikkhu su āvāsesu isasiyaṃ pūjā parkule
su ca. Mameva katamaññantu gihipaṃ bajitā ubo. Mameva ativāsā
asu su kiñcā kiñcesu
kismiñci. Iti balasse saṅkappo icchā māno ca vaṇḍhati ti. というあの2つの偈でございます
あの まずあの お経のお釈迦様の言葉の意味を理解して
それから えーと これが
誰に読めますかね 考古学者が来ないと Asataṃ Asataṃ
っていうのは ないもの bhāvanam bhāvanam
iccheyya bhāvan-
bhāvaっていうのはあるという意味で
ないものはあるのように iccheyya
期待するんですね じゃあそれは意味がわからないんですね
これはもう人間の性格のことなんです
ある一部の人間がいるんだそうで
自分にないいろんな徳
良いところとか 本当はないんですが
それはあるの如く他人が知ってほしいんです
ということで で これはまあ
まあ人間っていうのはね
やっぱりまあいろいろ私にあれもできる
これもできるとかね まあ世界にいて
自分の立場っていうものはね
まあ築いておきますから
それはあるものだったらね
例えば まあ早稲田大学卒業していたならば
早稲田卒業して卒業生やと言ってもよろしいし
自分にあるものだからね
大学に入ったこともなく
もうそういう大学卒業しているんだとか言ったりすると
それはないものあるということになります
まあ日本ではまあそういうケースいくつかが出たんだからね
政治の世界で あの自分のこういう学問の経歴を書いて出すところで
なんとかアメリカのなんだらかんだら大学卒業しましたとかなんとか書いたりして調べたら
それはもうそういうことはなかったっていうことになって
二人ですね 無駄目になったんだからね
それがやっぱりないものをあると言ってしまう謎
まあそれで自分の立場ね
築いてもらおうということなんですよ
だから まあこれっていうのは決していいわけじゃない
明らかにね 真面目な人は決してやることじゃないんです
謙虚な人もやることじゃないんです
この詐欺とかいろいろインチキ
ごまかしでとにかく自分の立場築きたいんです
そうするともうあるものもないものも混ぜてもう一発で言っちゃえば
みんなもう全部まとめてああそうですかとと思ってしまいます
学歴に限らず いろんな人間っていうのはね
ありがたがるものっていうのはいくらでもありますよ
まあもう 例えば自分がね
全く嘘をつかない人であると
正直な人であるという人格的なこと
もうよく頑張る人だと怠けませんよとかね
そういうふうに人間大事に思うこととかね
自分にないにも関わらず
あるのごとく言い張ったりする
その中でね まあ一番危ないところはこの精神的に優れているとかね
瞑想に達しているんだとか
悟りに達しているんだとか
言い張ることはもう一番仏教ではもうダメなんですね
そういうふうなことはもう出家には禁止
言ってもいけないんだ
会っても言ってはいけないし
ないにも関わらず言っちゃうと
それで出家はクビなんです
もう復活もさせません
それぐらい厳しくもう戒めてあるんです
ないものはあるのごとく見せてはいけませんし
それは普通の社会ででも困るんですね
まあ嘘を言ってるし 人を騙してるしね
で なぜ普通の社会でも困るというと
例えば能力はないのにも関わらず
自分にあると言っちゃうと
その人々にそういうことを頼むでしょうに
大変危険なんですよ 例えば
自分と同じ名前の誰かがちゃんとした医学を卒業して
その人の卒業証明書を持ってきて
免許証を持ってきて 名前が同じだからね
で 私は医者だよと言ったら
ああそうです じゃあ先生お願いしますと言っちゃうとどうなるんですかね
大変なことになりますよ
時々そういうね ちゃんと勉強しないで医療活動したとかね
もう逮捕されたりする人々もいるでしょうね
だからこの社会に対してはすごい迷惑
本人がちっぽけな何か儲かるだけの話で
本人にも大したことを得られるわけじゃないし
それよりも社会にかかる迷惑っていうのはかなり大きいんですよ
だから まあちょっとぐらい嘘を言ったっていいんじゃないかというふうに
それだけは軽く見ない
仏教は 自分の人生について
自分が持ってないものは決して言ってはいけないんです
謙虚な人は自分持っている徳さえもあまり言わない
言いふらしませんだけどね
自分にあるものは言ったってもね
それはそんなに問題ではありません
謙虚な人なら まあまあ
それもそんなに言ったりはしませんし
あるいは相手が理解して信頼してほしい場合は言うしかないし
例えばお釈迦様はその時その時に限って
ものすごい ものすごい力強く自分のことを言うんですね
もう自分には値する生命はいませんと
その場合 確かにその通りであるし
そう言われると お釈迦様のもう状況だからね
名刺ですからね それを見たら
聞く人々はやっぱりじゃあ聞いてやろうではないかと
話をということになりますが
それも生命に対し慈しみを持って人を助けてあげたいんだから言うんであって
お釈迦様がとにかく仕事欲しくて
そんなことをおっしゃってるわけじゃないんです
世間ではなんとかな仕事欲しくて
自分持っている経歴とかなんとかとか言ったりはする
それが悪いわけじゃないんですが
性格的なところの場合はね
とにかくないものは言ってはいけません
それで あまりも自分のことを言い出したりする人々もいますね
ちょっと言い過ぎというかね
その場合は明確に危ないんです
あまりも言いたくなると
大体はお互いちょっと疑問なんです
だから発見する方法っていうのはそんなところ一つなんですね
いつでも自分のことをベラベラベラベラあれやこれやとかね
いろいろもうなんか証拠のような
いろんなものを見せたりとか
あんまり自分を宣伝すると怪しいっていうことの方がすごい重いんです
実際 いろいろ資格持ってる人っていうのは
そんなに言い張ったりはしません
それで謙虚でいてほしいっていうのは当たり前のことで
謙虚にいるのは当たり前なんですけど
人々を助けるためには
たまたま自分の何者かと牙を見せてあげないとまずい時もあります
それは相手を助けるためなら
それはいいんですけど
なんでこれがすごい重大な問題で
比丘なら出家も取り消されるぐらい大きい罪かというと
これは人々に対してすごい迷惑なんです
例えば修行もしない もうブッダの教えさえも分かってない愚か者たちは
私は悟りましたとよく言うんですよ
とにかく悟りましたという人に限って
ブッダの教えさえも分かってないんです
何も知らない いますよ
悟ったと言うんですけど
お釈迦様はもう五戒ということを守りなさいと教えている
それさえも知らない それで一般の人々は乗ってしまうんですよ
必ず乗りますよ なぜかというと
ないものを言う場合は
結構からくりをして演じて言わなくちゃアカンだからね
それなりのいろんなね
もう圧倒されるためのいろんな目ぶり手ぶりやら
もう発表する方法や いろんなものをしなくちゃアカンだから
それによって騙されて
もう全く悪の道に人々は導いてしまっちゃいますよ
だから社会にとって 仏教の場合はそれはとても危ないことでね
人々の心をね 育てる方法っていうのは法則的に決まってますからね
それは誰にもどうすることもできないしね
だから 例えば仏教のことについて
私あんまりわかりませんだけど
知ってる範囲ではとかね
で 語る場合はあまり危険じゃないんですよ
たとえその人間違ったことを言ったってもね
よくわからないんだけど
まあこんなことじゃないかなと
聞いた人は まあまあ 自分で調べればいいし
納得いかない場合は しかし逆に
もう私に聞きなさいと
私ほど知っている人はいませんよと
言うと もう騙されてしまうんですね
まあそういうことで アサタンバハナ イッチャイヤっていうのは
自分にないものはあると言いたくなる
言ってしまうこと プレカーランチャ ビククス
比丘たちの間で自分がもう指導というか
もう前に立ちたいと リーダーシップを私に出してほしいという期待するんです
で 上座に自分が座りたくなるとか
そう座らなくても 大体比丘たちが集めたところで年の順番で座りますけど
仕事をしたりやるのは能力順番なんですね
ですから サンガの中ではこれもちょっとした問題なんですよ
比丘たちがどこかで何か用事で集めたら
もうみんな年の順番で何のことなく座る
では仕事を誰がやるのかっていうことになったら
一番トップの長老がやるべきっていうことじゃありません
その場合は能力順番になります
説法は誰がするのかというと
必ず一番トップに座っている長老をしなくちゃいけないということは全くないんです
能力順番で資格順番で仕事は資格順番で
人々を尊敬する場合は年上の順番で
ということで ですから
自分をリーダーにしたがっちゃうと
その人はもう他のお坊さんたちに仕事を分けてあげることも
その人のことになって
もうみんな導く羽目になっちゃいますからね
プレカーラっていうのはもう何か
一応そういうリーダーシップのことで
次 アーワーセーすちゃイッサリアン
アーワーサっていうのは比丘たちが住んでいるところで
ところ そちらにイッサリアンっていうのはまたトップの立場なんですね
管理者というかね 現代風に言えば住職なんですね
僧房だけなんですけど
お寺っていうのは現代の言葉で
で それでお坊さんたちのお寺で
住職は私が住職になりたいと
その管理責任を私に頼んでほしいとと思うこと
プージャパラクレーすちゃ
それで出家の人々が村に入ったら
村で人々はね お布施をしたり
尊敬したり いろいろ托鉢の習慣があった時はね
もうかなり便利でしたからね
在家の人々は自分の村で田んぼを畑仕事していればよろしいし
お寺と言ったってお坊さんどこかに住んでるだけで
午前中は村に入るんですからね
村に入ったらそこで説法も聞いて托鉢もお布施もして
それで午前中そういう仕事を終了したら
お坊さんたちはまた森に戻ったりする
だからそれぞれ便利に仕事はちゃんとうまくいくんです
お坊さんたちも在家の方々に説法して仏教を教えたことになるし
村の人々にも苦労して森に入って
山に入って もう家を放り出しちゃってね
そういう苦労する必要はないんです
で 畑 田んぼを作っている人が突然説法を聞きたくなっちゃうと
もう畑の作業をやめて森に入らなくちゃいけないんです
そうなってくると家族が困ったりするし
それで そういうんです
そういう問題は何も起こらなかったんです
で 例えばもう男の人がもう田んぼで仕事をして
もう朝からいて お坊さんたちは托鉢に出て
もう家の奥さんたちやらもう托鉢のお布施をして
それでご飯食べて終わったところで
もし奥さんがね うちの人も何か説法を聞きたい聞きたいと言っていたんですけど
もうどういうことも朝早くから田んぼに行ったんだよと何か言っちゃうと
お坊さんがどこでしょうかと
で そちらに行って説法してもう森に入るんです
だからその人には何の経済的な負担も何もないんです
田んぼの方にお坊さんが行くんだから
畑の方に お坊さんたちは修行しか
別にどこか仕事をしているわけじゃないし
会社に行ってるわけじゃないんだから
まあ昼間はもう村でいたっても構いませんし
昔はそういうふうに便利にはできてあったんですけど
今の社会とは違いますしね
そういうことで 一旦村に入ったら
在家の人々は自分のことを尊敬して欲しがるんですね
このその性格を そういうことでは困りますよということなんです
だから 在家ででも自分をとにかく出したくて出したくて出したくている人っていうのは
結局出家したっても こんな醜い性格は直らないんですよ
だからそこら辺に注意しているんですね
次の偈 マメーワ カタマンニャント
これの意味なんですけど
注釈書の意味 で理解するしかないんですけど
あの いろいろことをね
良いことを人間しますからね
そういうことが私がやったんだよという風にみんな知ってほしいんですね
例えばもう村のお寺に入ってみたら
ものすごい綺麗に掃除をして
綺麗に整理整頓してあると
それと行く人々はみんなよく整理整頓してるんでしょうとかね
住んでるお坊さんたちがやって
誰がやってるか大体わからないはずなんですけど
そこでこのこの人々はなんとなくどうですかね
綺麗でしょうとかね 一言葉言ったりするんです
綺麗ですねと言った一言葉でもうアウトなんですよ
アウトっていうのは まあこれは自分がやったように思わせたい
思わせた思わせたいんですね
ギヒィ パッバ ジタ ウボ
在家の人であろうか 出家であろうか
みんな自分がやったように思って思って欲しがるんです
例えばお寺にお客さん
お坊さんが来たら どうですか？すごく落ち着いている場所でしょう
ちゃんとお坊さんが来たっても
ちゃんとお客のお坊さんにもちゃんと用意してあって
結構こちらではこういうことでとか
いろいろ紹介したり 連れて行ったりとかね
さっさと連れて行って
これはこちらでこちらの水は用意してありますからと
こちらは食事をする場合はこちらでできるようにちゃんと綺麗にしてますよとかね
それでお坊さんたちが来たらこういうところで住んでもらっちゃいますよとかね
全部そうやってやると
なんか全部自分がやってるような感じになっちゃうんですね
マメーワ アティバサース
アティバサーっていうのは
このいつでも自分をリーダーにしてほしいというか
何かあったら私に事わってほしいって私に聞いてほしいというね
どうすればいいか どうすればいいかということ
みんな何をやっても自分に聞いてほしいんです
だからどうすればいいかということは
教えてあげる能力ない人に限ってそうなっちゃうんです
何か聞かれたらすごく喜んで
もうすごいもういろいろあれやこれやと言うかもしれませんだけど
結局全部ダメなんです
能力ないんだから その人に
能力ある人っていうのはもう忙しいんだからね
何か頼むとうるさいんだからね
誰かに聞きなさいよと追い出すのは普通なんですけど
能力ない人々は待ち構えているんです
もう私に聞いてくださいという風に
それはアティヴァサース
キッチャーキッチャーヤスキスメティ
キッチャーキッチャーというのはいろいろ行事やることですね
いろんなやらなくちゃいけないことをできちゃうと
じゃあ私に聞いてくださいということ
気持ちで 今までのこのもう明確なきめ細かな説明で
ポイントはアサタンバハヴァナミッチヤという行に全部濃縮しているんです
だからアサタンバハヴァナミッチヤっていうのは堅固で
もう言葉で アサタンというのはもうないものがあるのごとく自分にあるのことを期待するというね
それはどういうことかと
それからもう淡々と説明しただけ
この偈の中で お釈迦様の言葉っていうのは
ものすごい厳密な論理構成で成り立ってますよと
プロポジションがあって
その原因がそれからいて
それから結論で どんな四行でもそういう風に成り立っています
そういうことで こちらでアサタンバハヴァナミッチヤっていうのはプロポジションで
こういうことであると
それは原因で これこれこれであると
では 結果としてどうなるのかということを最終最後の行で言うんです
イティバアラッササンカッポ
イッチャーマノチャワッダティ
イティ このようにこのようであると
バアラッササンカッポ
愚か者の思考はこのようなものであると
愚か者の頭はいっぱいそればっかり考えている
どうすれば自分がアピールできるか
自分がアピールできるかと
だから自分をアピールすることは
出家世界ではもうそれだけ
それはその時点でもう禁止です
自分を売り込んではならんです
そのように愚か者は考えている
イッチャーマノチャワッダティ
それで結果としてこの人は悟るんじゃなくて
何を成長するのか イッチャー
イッチャーっていうのは欲望ですね
あれこれと欲しい欲しいと
イッチャーは日本語でどうなってます？国語
よく知ってる誰かがこれ見て
慢心ですか  慢心じゃないんです
欲求 欲求ですね だからこれ言っちゃあ欲求だけだから
これかなり精神的な不安定なんですよ
内面的にはハラッポなんですね
だからかなり欲求がいっぱいあるんですね
だからそれ自体が怖い煩悩なんです
それから慢心もかなり怖い煩悩なんです
この人は出家しているのに
毎日修行して育てるのは
そういう欲求と慢心であると
そういうわけでもう初めからもう話にならないという
その気持ちあると もう仏道に入ったって意味がないんです
仏道に入ればみんな悟るわけじゃないんですよ
悟らなくたって みんな一生懸命
まあまちな人間になろうということに頑張ってますから
だから自分が出家だぞとか
みんな私のことを尊敬してほしいとかね
そういうふうな態度をとっちゃうと
もう何もその人は得られません
得られるどころか どんどん性格的には堕落していくんです
だからもう初めからもそういう
これだけは仏教はもう厳しく戒めてあるんです
あまりにも厳しいんですよ
その時点の厳しい戒めは
仏教ではね 追い出してもあなた仲間ではないと追い出すっていうことはだいたいないんです
どんな失敗したっても
何とかして もうそれはもう賛記してもらって
また復活してもらうんですね
しかし 比丘の立場そのものも完全に取り消す
免許はもう取り消されるという
それはこの悟りの瞑想のことを言い触らしたりすることなんですね
だから あっても言わない世界なんです
精神的に何か状態に達したって
それはもう言わない で
何にも関わらず言っちゃうと
もう出家としての免許は取り消し
復活は不可能 二度と出家することもできない
出家させるなよと で そうでないと
もう何回還俗したり また出家したり
これは全然大丈夫です
この決まり破ったらもう失格
それからは だからどういうことはその人
だからその人は在家で瞑想して悟れないかというと
在家で瞑想して悟れますよ
しかし 悟れるんでしょうかと
そんな性格だったらありえないんです
だからそういう自分を嘘でアピールすること
本当のことアピールすることも気持ち悪くて情けないんですけど
嘘を言ってアピールすることはもう断言的にアウト
意味がない 仏道の世界ではその人は
心成長する世界ですから
もう失格ですね だからお釈迦様がもうなんでそんなことを教えているんでしょうかと
つまらないでしょうとかね
大事な戒律にそれしたって
もっと大事な戒律があるんじゃない
それは仏陀にはかなわないんだからね
お釈迦様が言ったことを守るしかない
そういう風になっていますから
よく覚えておいてください
それで皆様は出家じゃないんだからね
皆様皆様で出家のことを言うと地味に真剣に聞くんですけど
自分たちに関係あることを言うと
もう関係ないってことで聞いてますからね
これで結構私は困ってますけど
いろいろこれはどうすれば
あれはどうすればとよく聞くんですけど
あんたに関係ないで言いたくなるんですよ
出家に行ったことは出家に行ったことで
在家に行ったこと 在家に行ったことで
どうしてもあべこべなんですよ
魚だったら泳げばいいのに
魚がどうやって飛べばいいかと聞くし
鳥だったら泳げる 飛べばいいのに
鳥になったところでどうやって泳げるのかと
どちらでもできませんだからね
あべこべでしょう 鳥だったら飛び方について心配したり
いろいろ学んだりするのは当たり前で
魚だったら泳ぎ方についていろいろ心配したり学んだりするのは当たり前であって
だから在家は在家に説かれた仏教を学ぶ実践するのは常識なんですけど
まあ知らない私は本当に
そこでまあ その問題は俗世間でも本当に困る問題なんですよ
失格の人 資格がない人がいろんなところに入り込んじゃうと
もうみんなにすごい迷惑
だからすごい重い罪になりますよ
例えば嘘と言えば嘘な
まあ嘘ってそんなだから軽い嘘ではない
軽い嘘じゃないんです
だからちょっとした嘘でしょってことで処理はできません
まあ日々いろんな嘘を言ってますけどね
不倫しながら奥さんにはもう私はあなたのことしかもうもう女は見えませんよとかね
もうとんでも真っ赤な嘘なんですけど
それはもうすごい迷惑もうということにはないんですからね
社会に損害とかね それはないんでしょうに
だからそういう嘘はそれなりに何とかもうで何とかできますからね
この場合は自分に資格もないのに
あれこれあれこれといって
いろんな立場に入り込んで
それからもうすごい巧みに言葉巧みにそういう人々は言いますからね
だから詐欺師は一番納得
説得力ありますからね
本物よりは そこで人間が困る
人間困らせるんだから
これすごい大きな罪になっちゃうんです
そんなことで  それでこの瞑想を実践する方々にとっては
この自分の修行を成功したいという気持ちがあるならば
これはもう毒になるんです
この性格は まずこういう性格だったらもう意味がない
やっても だからこの素直でいること
正直でいること また謙虚であることっていうのはね
これ基本的に必要なんです
だから指導者 指導を受ける時でも
まあ自分で判断して この状態に達した
あの状態に達したというと
もう何もできません もうアドバイスもできないし
本人の精神状態でどんな位置にいるかっていうことももうわからなくなっちゃうんです
時に瞑想指導する時は
人の言葉はそのまま理解しません
こちら仏教側は いつでも中身と精神状態で見ているんです
例えば「私は今無常を見るように
見られるようになりました」と言われた瞬間 「
あ 臭い」と思っちゃうんです
これはもう それからもうこちらの頭回転しなくなっちゃうんです
瞑想って 瞑想 本当の別に違いますからね
心の変化っていうのは
だからこれを教えたっても危ないしね
どうせそういう性格の人が多いんだからね
ずっと私はね もうもう本当に時間もないしね
たくさんの人々に会うこともできないし
だから瞑想のやり方と
もう自分で心をチェックする方法とかね
それを本にまとめたいんですけどね
やっぱりまとめたいと思う瞬間に
またやっぱりやめた方がいいということにいつでもなるんですよ
だからずっと私のすごいもうもう私にも先がないんだからね
ものすごく時間無駄になっちゃうんですよ
だから基本的な瞑想のやり方ばっかり言っていて
もうそれからどうなるかどうなるは
本人がそれぞれ一人一人修行して報告しなくちゃいけないしね
それだったらまあ基本的なとこっていうのはどったことはないんだから
それはもうちゃんと勉強して学んで
何かちょっと違うことが起きたら
まあアドバイスするならば
かなりたくさんの人々にね
道を教えられますけど
これがね 危ないって もうどれほどブッダの言葉
ブッダの名前を借りて詐欺やってるのかというと
この国で 我はブッダだよという連中がね
結構いるし あっちこっち本にあるところどころとかね
もうパクったりして 自分が発見したこととか喋ったりするしね
それで結構人は騙されるし
そういう人が現れるのもみんなかなりのもうカモだからなんです
だって反論しないし 疑問持たないし
質問しないし ディスカッションはない
それっていうことは 言われた通りに鵜呑みにするっていう性格なんです
ものすごい危ないんです
だから いくらでも詐欺師の場合はいい畑というかね
もう栄養も全部ついていて
もうただ種だけ置いておけばサッと成長する
だからどう考えたって瞑想中ははいはい
これから今これは預流果の境地ですよとか
それはないと思いますけど
それはただの言葉なんですけど
今私は第一禅定に達してますという人はいるんですよ
私は疑問 どうやって第一禅定だと分かったんでしょうかと
もうあの 何て言いますか
ボクシングの場合はもう第三ラウンドとか
そういうの看板持ってきますけどね
瞑想の中はそうはないんです
だから全て中身の勝負なんです
ある心の状態に説法するときはお釈迦様がもう用語を使っただけのことで
だから用語に乗るんじゃないんです
結構用語に乗って 今これこれ感させてる
今これこれ感じてるんだというと
私ははい どうぞ頑張ってくださいと
それしかもう言葉がないんですよ
それもやめてるわけじゃなくて
それでも頑張ったら もしかすると心が変わる可能性ありますね
変わってきたら まあこの傲慢を捨てるだろうと
捨てて素直になるでしょうと
だから報告するべきは自分の心境
心の状態なんです 今こんな調子でやってますよと
だから その状態がブッダの用語から見ればどういうものかということを第三者には言えますけど
まあ悟りに達したら本人わかるっていうことは昨日の講演で説明しました
まあそれもまあ昨日初めて行ったんであって
もう仏教の本読んだっても出てこないんです
お釈迦様の言葉の中では
悟った人は悟ったと知ってるんだよということで
それで終わってるんです
悟ったならば 本人知ってるんだよと
それは心理学的にどういうことかとね
説明しましたんですけど
とにかくこのだからこの肩書きで言いたくなるということはね
例えばね 石原さんとかね
もう随分昔ね 博士号とかね
修了して終わってそうなっている
で 石原さんがこれが博士って何か得たかというと
そうはないんですよ 本人が言われる通りにグタグタグタグタ研究して
発表するところでもう決まってますから
その発表もして それから研究したものをまとめて出して
それで面接で まあそれでいいやということにね
教授たちが言うし それで面接はうまくいったということに終わる
それで終わりですよ それでまあ下らんお祭りで
何か紙に汝はなんだらかんだらとか
それだけの話で それも学校の先生たちがそれを紙をくれるであって
自分で書いたって意味がないし
一応その卒業証明書が出せなくても
論文がOKになって面接もOKになったら
それで博士なんです 終わったら
だからまあ中身ですよ
結局は ただ便利さを考えて
まあ学士とか博士 修士とか博士とかいろいろ名前をつけてる
それも学校も自分が自分勝手で名前をつけてるだけの話で
問題はそうじゃなくて
まあこれぐらいのことを学んだら我々はこんな名前を言いますよというぐらいの話で
その名前に MBBSという名前に何か価値があるわけじゃないんです
だから逆にそういうMBBとかなんだらかんだらつけちゃうと
世間がこれぐらいのことを学んでいるだろうと推測するんです
ですから この位はどうしても他人からもらわなきゃダメということになります
でもその中身ある人にとっては
それはどうでもいいんですよ
そういう卒業証紙があってもなくても
自分の立場は変わるわけないんだからね
だからこの性格的なことで
私は今こういうものを得ているんだよと何か
か そういうね もう痛くなることをちょっとかなり危ないんですよ
だからまあ 自分がどのような心成長しているのかっていうところだけね
成長しているかっていうことも
この修行中っていうのはあんまりわからないと思いますけどね
真面目に修行してみると
これっていうのはものすごく難しくって
もうなかなか大変でしょうしね
こんな余裕がないんです
あ 今何だらかんだらの境地でございます
こんな妄想ばっかりでしょうね
それだったら もう必死で絶えず観察する羽目になるだけでね
余裕はないと思いますしね
そういうことで この性格の場合は
これ基本的にも直しておかないといけないことで
もう全く完璧に謙虚で
頑張らないと成長には結構問題が起きるんです
逆に俗世間的に言えば
このすごいもう人類に対してはもうとんでもない迷惑なんです
例えば出家で出家の場合でも
そういう詐欺師があれやこれやと言っちゃうと
もうその人に限って もう巧みにもう自分をアピールするんだから
他の出家はアピールすることが何ともなく
あのもう自分のことで精いっぱいでいるんだから
もう あのお坊さん 本当に親切でお寺に行ったらすぐ飛んできて
もうよく面倒見てくれるんだと
あれはこそお坊さんやと
という一重はめになるんです
そう言われたいしね しかし
仲間がない人だから みんなにダメージ与えるんです
だから仏教はそういう人間のことで結構困ってきた歴史ありますから
経験のある仏教はよく知ってます
すぐもう知ってますけど
それでもあの一般人をガードして守ってあげることは無理ですよ
あの人はもう本当にもうとんでもない人
邪魔だなと分かってますけど
これ 一般人を騙すことは守れないんです
だから危険もばっかりなんです
例えば ある真面目に修行するお坊さんたちがグループがあって
そちらにこの詐欺師が一人入っているんだと
いうと その人ばっかりもう前に出てみんなに喋ったり
案内したり 教えてあげたり
じゃあ教えてあげますよ
どうぞどうぞとか何とかやってますからね
そうすると 他の仲間の人々を知っていたっても
仲間の坊さんたちは割り込んできて
この人の話聞くなよと言えますかと
前に出ませんだからね
だからそれも戒めてますからね
人のことをガチャガチャ言うなよと
そこはちょっとした問題なんです
時々私にあの直接たまたまあのこういう風に教えていますけど
何だらかんだらさんがね
あれってどうでしょうかねと聞いたっても
私に何の反応もできませんよ
言われるとすぐ分かりますけどね
これ何やと でも言ったらその人を批判したことになるんです
ある人にはっきり言ったんで
私は会ったこともない
人のことをなんで私はここでそれはこういうことやこういうことだと判断できるの？するのかと
あんた今言ってる人には会ったこともない
もし私がよく会ったことがあって
話を聞いたことがあって
そういうことだったら何者かと言えますけど
だからそれはもう分かりませんと
一人この聞いたことは
この誰かさんがね 自分がちゃんと悟ってるんだとね
よく言っていて だからあんたどう思いますか？とかね
うん 私は会ったことがないで
その人に だからその人本当に悟っているのかないのか
私はどうやって判断するんですかと
言って まあまあ これこれやと言ってもらったけど
そんなこと言われたっても
私はそれで判断できませんよと
できません 判断する なんて言います
必要もないんだと もしその人が悟っているならば
それはありがたいことで
悟っていないにも関わらず悟っていると言うんだったら
それは残念なことで 言えるのはそれだけですよと
で これからもうずっと私は一旦口を開けたら止めませんだからね
まあしょうがないだからね
で まあ本人にいろいろ本人に疑問するんですね
私は  そういうことだから
この だからその質問した人にしても
私はやっぱりその この
その人が詐欺師に騙してほしいという気持ちは全くないし
その人もこの質問したこと特別なケースなんですけど
で 騙されて詐欺師に騙されてほしくもないし
ちゃんとブッダの道を修行して悟りに達する可能性があれば悟りに達してほしいという慈しみもあるんだけど
どうやって助けてあげるのかと
その場合は そんなあんた言ってる人悟ってないんだよ
どうやって私は言うんでしょうかね
そんなことばっかし言ったら
なんか私は人の徳を片っ端からけなす人間になるでしょうに
人の徳はものすごく褒めてあげなさいということは決まりでしょうし
私たちの育ち方っていうのは
人を持ってる もう悪人であろうが
何かいいところないのかと探す方法なんです
そういう色眼鏡なんですね
お釈迦様にくれているのは良いところを見る
見えるという 聞いてるのは悪いところは何なのかと
そういう目を目を持ってはいけないんです
それも一つの煩悩の一つなんです
人の悪いところしか見えませんと
人の悪いところしか見えない人には
自分の心になってくると自分のいいところしか見えないんですよ
そうするとどっちでもダメで成長しないんですよ
必要なのは逆なんです
自分の悪いところばっかし見える
そうなってくると悪いところって嫌だからね
なんとか頑張っちゃいますよ
人の良いところ見えちゃうと真似するんです
[背景の音楽]それを
それで自分の人格は向上する
だからそれがあるんだから
お釈迦様がもう性格的には人の良いところ見える尺度と自分の悪いところを見える尺度を持ちなさいよと
ということがまた反対ネガティブ言葉で言ってます
なぜかというと 今私が言ったことではまた矛盾を成立するんだから
お釈迦様そういうのは言ってない
それは反対 自分を持ち上げることと
他人を見下す性格とやめなさい
一つにしているんです
自分を持ち上げる気持ちと他人を見下す気持ち
これをワンセットにして
それはあってはならない性格であると
だから否定形で言うんだからぴったしの言葉で
私は言ったのはもう肯定形でね
自分の良いところを見て
自分の悪いところを見ない
それはこうやって それはちょっと実践上では問題にあるんです
だからお釈迦様って本当にすごい見事なんですよ
例えば自分の悪いところばっかり見ちゃうと
結局は頑張るかもしれませんだけど
落ち込んじゃって何もできなくなる可能性もあります
だからそれ言ってないんです
いくらやっても自分がダメだ
これはもうもう話にならんやと言って
もうもう全部諦めて放り投げるということもあります
それをお釈迦様は知ってます
だから自分が修行しながらどのように到達したかというところは
上達とかよかったよかったと自分を褒めてあげてくださいと
それで変なところ やっぱりこれがダメだとちゃんと厳しく戒めなさいということがブッダの正しい言葉なんです
そうなってくると 自棄喧嘩に陥ったりとかね
放り投げたくなったりとかはないんです
だから仏道では問題は起こりません
とにかく精神的な未練も
そういう風にものすごい見事に
もう信じられない完璧さ
言葉 単語を使う時でも
だから否定形で もう他人を見下す気持ちと自分を持ち上げる気持ちは抑えなさいと
そういうことあるんだからね
もうこちらに来たって
もうあの宗教はどうでしょうか
本人は悟っていると言っているんだから
とかね 知らんてそんなことはね
私関係ないというね 本人に私は疑問したんです
だからその人 そういう悟っている人のところにずっとあんた教え
どれぐらい教え 結構教えになっていたんだと
あのね なんでこちらに来たんですかと
こちらに来る必要ないんだよと
悟っている人と言っている人の宗教組織に入って教えになっていて
また仏教の瞑想会に来て
だからそれ言いながら
私はこれでもこの言葉まずいと自分で終わっちゃうんです
私はもうはっきりそこで言ったつもりですからね
それだけで だからアホな自分にさえも疑問持ってるんだから
その人の言葉に対して
この人はそんな能力ある人でもなかったし
もうそんな判断能力もなかったし
そんな程度の知識であの開祖様のことを見ていたその人がやっぱり疑問を持ってるんですね
だからまあ自分で考えればいいということでね
ちょこっと考えるために必要なポイント
なんで来たのかと とにかくこの人間はね
不完全で生まれて不完全でしょう
生命はね それで人格向上して
人格完成して 悟りに達しなくちゃいけない
それはもう 何て言いますかね
それを達したらそれが人間の道でしょうね
人格を完成しなくちゃいけないというのは当たり前の話でしょうね
だらしない人格でいいわけじゃないでしょうね
それは道であるし その道を実践するためには
もう詐欺はダメなんです
詐欺師 インチキではすたまれませんね
ですから これも煩悩の一つですから
もう誰にでもそのウイルスはあります
まあ自分が出て自分を認めてほしいというね
このウイルスはもう消えるところまでしっかりとしなくちゃいけないんです
それは瞑想する前に もう出家する人々にはもう随分前にそれはもうなくすようにしておくんです
何て言いますかね この仕事が始まる前に用意してしなくちゃいけない資格の一つなんです
じゃあまあまあ それぐらいの
だから涅槃についてとか何とかとか
あまりこの芸の中で入ってないんですけど
そういう思考があると
愚か者はね まあ私のこと
私のことと私 私とかね
そういう風になってくると
まあ仏道でなくなっちゃいますね
もう言っちゃうとマナだけ増えるんだから
もう話にならない 人格向上じゃないんです
欲求と傲慢だけどんどんどんどん上がっちゃうと
このストーリーはあるんですけど
もうすごい長くて 単語がありまして
このたった一つの単語があって
それが意味がわからなくて
ストーリーは言えないんです
辞書にもないとは思います
この単語は あの サイケの信者さんの中で
このチッタという名前のあるサイキ信者さんがいて
まあこの人はすごい大物なんですね
仏教の弟子たちの中で
で 彼に関わる経典もあるんです
サンユッタニカーヤにセクション一つありますよ
ということは まあすごい人なんです
預流果 不還果まで悟ったんですけど
ブッダに会ったことはない
それで派手にお釈迦様に会いに行ったんです
1ヶ月とかかけて 私は不還果にまで達していますけども
ブッダに会ったことはないと
だからその人のこの徳の高いことで
で 智慧の高いことでね
大変な大きな大騒ぎになって
大祭りで もう で  1ヶ月間かけてものすごいグループでお坊さんたちも経典はどうせちょっと経典じゃ注釈書はちょっと大げさですから
なんでもかんでもね 比丘たちは500人で
比丘尼たちも500人と
在家の女性男性 また500人 500
人 信者さんがね そうすると何人？ 2000人連れて行ったんだと
それで2000人の食料やら何でもかんでももう車に乗せて
2000年もう道は 1ヶ月間かかります
長いんだから なんかちょっと普通のスケールじゃない
本当にそれを置けたならばね
まあかなり大騒ぎになったでしょうね
2000人も連れて行ったかどうか
そこは置いておいても
まあ騒ぎになって お釈迦様に会って
お釈迦様のあの足の前のところの細いところ
なんて言いますか かかとのちょっと上のところ
足首 それでもお釈迦様に会って
お釈迦様の足首を両手にとって
両手でこうやって触って礼をしたんだと
で  悟ってない人はブッダの体触ったら大変なことになりますけど
それはやりませんし で
不還果になってるんだからね
もう煩悩はもうほとんどないんですからね
で そういう人々はもう
もう何 体触ったって何やったって
お釈迦様別にもう何もおっしゃりませんしね
お釈迦様の足首を手に取って礼をしたんだと
その時は地震が起きたと
すごいことだよと 地震というか
これは地鳴りでしょうね
それぐらいかなりもう大事にハイライトしている方なんですよ
このチッタサンガ チッタサンガがいた地方でマッヂカサンダラという地方なんですけど
よくよく生活していてな
この五人比丘という 五人比丘はご存知ですね
あの お釈迦様に最初に
最初の説法を聞いた 5人ですね
その 5人の一人 もう最初にお釈迦様はみんな追い出しちゃったんだからね
60人の阿羅漢たちが現れたら
もうあんた方はもう もう悟っているんだから
この世の中でもう 61人いるんだよと
あっちこっち行きなさいよと
言って道を教えなさいよと
言ってもう外へ出しましたから
あまり戻ってこなかったんですよ
みんなそのまま だから悟ったらいかにブッダ
その方々を信頼するのかって当たり前ですけど
煩悩ないんだから その 5人の比丘の中でマハーナーマという大阿羅漢が
そのチッタサンガが住んでいるところ
そこの地方に行ったんです
それでマハーナーマ長老を見て
見ただけで すぐ違う人やということで
で 往生したりして 何か教えてくださいと言うと
説法したとされて それで預流果に達するんです
だからチッタさん自身がものすごく頭がいいんです
この最初のお坊さんたちっていうのは
ガチャガチャガチャガチャ説法するぐらいの
あんまりこのブッダはそれから説法し始めたんだから
仏教というのはそれから出来上がったものなんですよ
あらゆる用語やら単語やら
いろんな方便やらいっぱい
この方々 最初のグループはもう初転法輪といくつかの経典は聞いたことはありますけど
真理の内容だけね 基本的な
それからもう悟りに達して出て行ったんですよ
だからだいたいなんかそんなに詳しくあの説法できるってことでもなかったと思いますけど
しかし中身はあるんだからね
チッタさんがマハーナーマ大長老から説法を受けて預流果に達する
で それからかなり大きなお寺も作って
あらゆるお坊さんたちはそこら辺に来て修行できるようにと用意しておいたんですね
そこから在家として自分の責任を果たす
出家して修行する方々に修行できるようにしてあげるのは自分の仕事ではないかということ
そこでチッタさんがお坊さんたちの面倒を見るだけじゃなくて
ちょっともう何と言いますか
頭がいいすごい方だから
いろいろ質問したり どこまでやっているのかとか
そこまで心配するんですよ
普段は最強やらないことなんですけど
だから瞑想しているんだから
あの坊さんがありがたいとか
それもないんです 調べるというか
質問したりとかね だからモックスだけではなくて
お坊さんたちがちゃんと修行して修行に達しているのかというところまで心配する
そういうことだから 結構お坊さんたちは助かる
正直なお坊さんたちは助かるんですよ
やっぱりこれから修行したいんだから
チッタさんのところに行きましょうと
あの人怖いんだからということでそちらに行くんです
もう食事 ご飯の面倒を見て家に帰ってということはないんですね
だからもう監視するんだから
やっぱりそちらに行った方がもういいんじゃないかと
わからなかったことがあったら教えてくれるし
ただ我々ちょこっとでもふざけたり怠けたりしちゃうと
もう結構言われるでしょうと
だからその怖さをみんな怖いというかじゃなくてね
そこはもうちゃんと考えて
お坊さんたちそちらに行って修行して
結構完了して帰ってくる
そこを知った大阿羅漢サーリプッタ
モッガッラーナ両尊者が
モクレン尊者とサーリプッタ尊者がね
これ助かりますよ だからこの人の仕事だからね
出家する人々を解脱するまで面倒を見るのは
これチッタさんが地方に遠いところにいて
頑張っているんだと ちゃんとお坊さんたちの精神的な成長にもまで心配しているんだということで
これはすごいことだと自分たちが言って
そこはちょっとその人に反抗していかなくちゃいかんということになったんです
だからもうサーリプッタ両尊者が行って
その人を認めて帰ってくると
もうお坊さんたちにはなおさら文句言えなくなっちゃうんです
で その両尊者がそちらに行ったんですね
いらっしゃったらもう当然チッタさんが本当に喜んで
私に説法をお願いしますと
それはサーリプッタが本当はね
長旅でものすごく疲れてますよと
だから 明日ぐらいにしましょうという話ですけど
ですから あまり説法は今日はね
ちょっと遠慮しますけど
というより そんなちょっと教えてあげて
それでもね 一つちょっとだけ短く
それ聞いて不還果に達するんです
で 不還果っていうのは
在家の人々は不還果までですからね
もう在家でいるんだからね
阿羅漢になりたければ出家しないことちゃいけないんですね
で 彼が阿羅漢になることよりは
かなり仕事をしているんだからね
仏教のために だから出家はしてないんです
で すぐその場でサーリプッタモクレン尊者と弟子たちにお布施をしますと明日ということで
かなり派手に歓迎みたいなパーティーみたいに
もうかなり普通の托鉢ではなくて
しっかりもうみんなに食事を用意してお布施するつもりで
それでこのチッタさんが作ったお寺の管理人がスダンマというお坊さんなんです
名前は この二人の関係
どういう関係かと分かりませんだけど
なかなかこの二人がお互いにもうやり合いはしていたみたいです
とにかくチッタさんは負けませんし
お坊さんたちに文句言っちゃうし
スダンマさんも一応言い返したりしていたでしょうと思います
で チッタ居士はそれを全然何とも思わない
もう悟りに達しているし
しかし 自分のお寺に住職をやってるお坊さんの何かだらしないところ見たら何か言っちゃうとかね
でも本人がすごい信仰経験な仏教徒ですから
スダンマさんにも何の文句も言えなくて
まぁということで終わっちゃう
まぁとにかくサーリプッタ尊者に接待して招待してから
自分のお寺のお坊さんに言わなきゃとかね
丁寧に で みんなお寺のお坊さんたちはみんな一斉に
その人の家に行けばいいんですよ
午前 次の日 それでもチッタさんがそのお寺には
それでも特別に自分のお寺に管理しているお坊さんにも
まぁ言わなくちゃいけないんだと
それ言ったんですね 明日自分の家でね
特別にお布施を用意しますので
何を言おう このサーリプッタ尊者とモクレン尊者とその弟子たちのために
だからぜひ明日いらっしゃってくださいと
この人がこれ気に入らない
この言い方は スダンマという比丘は
これちょっと違うんじゃないかと
私はこのお寺の責任者で管理人だからね
まず私に断ってから言うのは筋ではないかと
で もうそれでちょっと機嫌が悪くなっちゃって
断ったんです 私は行きませんよと
そしたらもうチッタさんが 「
まあまああんたね そんなこと言うの
明日いらっしゃってください 」「
いいえ 行きませんが」と
何回この二人がもうやり合っちゃうんです
だから行ったとしても
チッタさんが最後までももう諦めません
もうあんたね 何言ったっても
とにかく明日来てくださいと言って帰ったんです
断ったことは認めません
めげないんです それでスダンマさんがもう次の日
心汚れてるんだからね
自分でも知りたいんですね
どんな風にこのお布施を用意しているのかとかね
で 自分がもう断ったんだから
自分が普通に托鉢に出たいんですね
で サーリプッタモクレン尊者は托鉢に出ません
その家に行くだけで どんな風に用意しているのかと知りたくなったんです
だから本人も朝 托鉢に出る人は朝早く出なくちゃいけないんです
接待がある場合はもう早く出なくてもいいんです
その家に行くだけだから
先にあっちこっち家何軒か托鉢しながら
チッタさんの家にも托鉢に入ったんです
入ったらもう自分がもうまた言って
ダメですよと 私は托鉢しますよと言うんだから
もう托鉢の分だけ食事あげて
で まあ用意してましたからね
もうたくさんの坊さんたちの食事をね
それを見て うん いかがでしょうか？って聞いたら
あんたもう結構立派に全部用意していますけどね
大丈夫やと しかし一つだけ欠けてますよと
一つは足らないんだよと言ったんですね
私は引っ掛けてるその一つなんですよ
これ何かとわからない
言葉はあるんだけどね
と ティラサーングランという単語なんですけど
ティラサーングランって何でしょうか？わからないんですね
ありますかね ミャンマー版で
そこまでエピソード書いてますかね
じゃあ私がちょっと書いて
書いてないね 何かないと言ったんですよ
とにかく  ティラサっていうのはゴマのことにも使うし
アングラっていうのは指っていうことで
だから何だここの意味はとわからない
私はもう しかし その言葉を聞いたところで
チッタ・ガハパティさんがチッタ・コチがすぐ気づいちゃったんです
富豪家だから別に でもこれは侮辱やと
だから普通だったらすごくなんかそういう
そういう何か一言は言ったんですね
だから何か一つの食事の何かでしょうね
お菓子の名前かもしれませんし
そこお菓子の名前を聞いて
そこまで傷つくということは何でしょうかね
これは私の推測で もしかすると
まあこの人は普通の人で
何か商売やって もう大金持ちになって
それからその商売じゃなくて
かなり大きなスケールで商売やっていた
もうすごい金 大富豪だからね
だから一番貧乏な時やっていた何かのことでしょうね
言ったのは だから今大富豪ですけど
昔はあんたろくに食べ物もなく苦労したんではないかということをなんじるような感じで
何かあんたこれ用意してないでしょ？と言って
まあこれにはもうチッタさんが言い返しちゃったんですね
で チッタさん もう不言家だからね
怒ることはまるっきりないし
その代わりに比丘たちを戒めるんだからね
在家でありながら 言ったらすごくゆっくり
お釈迦様の全く同じ手段で
まあブッダの弟子たちからね
まあ言われる言葉ですからね
だから私はちょこっとしたこのエピソードを思い出しますよと
どういうことですかと
言ったら 昔々 あの山から白鳥が
白鳥というのは渡り鳥ですからね
白鳥がもう飛んできたんだと村に
この白鳥は森にいたカラスと交尾したんだと
交尾してもう帰っちゃったと
そこでこの意味としては
白鳥というのは聖なるすごい品格のある優れた鳥で
カラスというのはもうスキャベンジャーだから
何といいますか スキャベンジャー
掃除人 掃除人というかゴミさらい
ゴミを処理するという
で すごい格が一番低いんです
だから このそこを意味するために象徴として取る鳥なんですね
白鳥といえば この梵天も白鳥と同じ象徴で合わせるし
涅槃解脱の場合でも たまたま阿羅漢たちは白鳥のごとく飛んでいきます
どこにも止まりませんよと使ってますね
白鳥はもう清らかさの象徴で
カラスはものすごい汚れたことの象徴なんですね
だから それをわからないとエピソードの意味がわからなくなりますからね
それで白鳥がカラスと交尾して
白鳥はもう渡り鳥だから出て行って
このカラスはもう卵を産んで
もうヒヨコ ヒヨコ？何でしたっけ
まあ子供を作って もうこのカラスが大きくなるんですね
それでこの生まれてきたカラス
もう鳥がカラスとも何とも言えないんだからね
結局はもうもうミックスだからね
俺の父親は白鳥だからと思ったりしてね
白鳥の声で鳴こうとするんです
で 始まるんだそうですね
白鳥のガーなんとか声がありますからね
始めてカーということで終わっちゃうんだと
それで母親がカラスだから
じゃあカラスの声で鳴いてやろうかなと思って
カーと始めて白鳥の声で終わっちゃうんだよと
それであなたね 偉大なるブッダの弟子で生まれてね
言ってる言葉はねと言ったんです
だから逆襲されたんですけど
これはものすごい厳しい逆襲なんです
生まれが悪いという意味ですからね
だから本人がカラスで
ただたまたま偉大なる仏のブッダの世界に至っても
口があなたのねと ということは言わない
ストーリーだけ終わって
つなぎだけ言って終わっちゃったんです
そういうわけで 偉大なる仏弟子たちの口からもね
まあそれほど素晴らしくない言葉が聞けますよと
これもうお坊さんがものすごく自分が逆に侮辱されたということで
プライドを傷ついちゃったということで
もうカンカンそれで怒ったんです
怒って もうそんなこと言うなら二度とあなたの寺の面倒見ないんだよと
言ってもうチッタサンガ
そんなこともそんなこと気にする必要ないでしょうと
いろんなことを言うんですよ
もうもうずっと仲良しでしょうしね
お互い様でしょうと だから
まあそんなことをお寺でお寺の面倒を見てくださいと
あなた出て行ったら 誰がお寺の管理するのかとか
お願いしてもしてももうダメ
出て行っちゃったんです
出て行っちゃって 結局ブッダのところに行ったんですよ
言ったらこの人が じゃあ在家が出家を侮辱していいのかと
仏弟子で 仏教でなければ別に問題はないんだけど
仏教徒だから これは間違いだと
仏教で過ちを犯したら
それは処理しなきゃダメなんですね
でお坊さんたちにお話をして
お坊さんたちもそれそんなこと言われると
これ侮辱ですね チッタサンガがそんなこと言ったならば
すごい侮辱ですよ 特にこの生まれについては
さぼることはすごい侮辱なんです
お釈迦様に言われたら
お釈迦様が何のこともなく
あのね あなたが間違ってますよと
罪を犯したのはあなたですよと
あなたがその方を侮辱したんだよと
で 恨まりますから チッタさんがもう不言化だからもう聖者の一人でしょうに
聖者に対して侮辱は本格的な侮辱だから
聖者が一般の凡夫の人に何言ったっても大丈夫です
聖者が戒める気持ちで侮辱する
お釈迦様を侮辱するんだから
それは戒めるんですから
もう自分はすいません
申し訳ない 謝ると謝るしかないんです
だからスダムム比丘が自分が比丘という覚を持っては比丘ではないかと
あの人は再起でしょうと
だから私は侮辱する権利はないという態度で
違いますよ お釈迦様は
言ってお釈迦様は命令するんです
あなたはもう戒律を犯してますよと
謝りなさい と言って そこでもうそのお寺
お釈迦様のところでもういられないんだよ
お釈迦様に命令されたんだから
そこで犯した戒律はサンゲでは済みません
その侮辱した人のところに行って謝らないと
謝ってから比丘の前でサンゲするんです
もうどうしようもなくなっちゃって
お釈迦様の前ではプライドはないんだから
どうしようもないんだから
もうもうもうもう向こうはもう絶対的権限だから
もうはい わかりましたということで
こそこそとまた衣を用意して出て行ったんですよ
チッタさんのところに出去っても
なかなか自分にとってはあの人の家にまたこそこそと行って
あの この前大変申し訳ございませんでしたと
私は謝りますと 言葉を取り消しますという一言言えないんです
何か食べ物の名前を言っただけですよ
その人は その他のチッタさんがもうエピソードまで持ってきたんだから
量で見ればチッタさんの方がもう量と気付くのレベルを見るとチッタさんの方が厳しいんですよ
だからスダムムさんもどこが納得いかないところあったり
でもブッダに言われたんだからしょうがなく
やっぱり言えないんですよ
家に入らないんですよ
それでこの人は一つの戒律を犯したままでいるはめになるんだから
でもどうしようもなく勇気が出てこない
また戻ったんです かなりもう本人がもう傲慢というのはもうほとんどもうない
もうものすごい惨め 謝らないで戻ったんです
なおさら惨めになっちゃう
またお釈迦様のところに来たら
その時だけお釈迦様はそこで優し慈しみを
使うんですね 一回行ったんだからね
本人が それは評価するんです
それで何にも言わないで
その場合はもう一人サポートに連れて行ってくださいという風に
また新しい戒律を決めるんです
在家の人に何か間違いを犯しちゃって
出家が謝る場合は サポートにもう一人連れて行くという
で サポートの比丘を認定したところで
二人で行くんですよ そうするといくらか勇気が出てきます
で チッタさんがスダッマさんとやり合って喧嘩しているんですけど
もう人のお坊さんがお坊さんだから
チッタさんが当然そのお坊さんにはすごい尊敬する
入るなよということは言えないんです
在家の家だから入るなよということは言えますよ
でもチッタさんがこのお坊さんにね
入るなよということを言えませんから
どうぞどうぞと言わなくちゃいけない
そうすると この間違いを起こしたお坊さんも後ろからそっといけるんです
行ったところでこのサポートのお坊さんが
じゃあもう行ってくださいと言うと
もうそこで謝ることができるんです
そこでチッタさんが行ったら
チッタさんがもう間違いもうはいわかりましたと
で 受けて それでまたあのお坊さん同士で懺悔して
それでもう問題は解決します
だから その出来事に対してお釈迦様が教えたというふうに
こちらは成り立ってますけどね
だから 愚か者は調子に乗るんだよというね
だからスダッマさんがすごいもう性格悪かったんだから
それでまた帰ってきたら
お釈迦様はこの偈を唱えてスダッマさんにも厳しく説法しましたと
それでスダッマさんも一応預流果の悟りに達するんです
だからまあそれで一件落着ということになりますけど
だから この自分が偉いとスダッマという比丘が思っていたんだから
何の悟りの成長もなかったでしょうし
これ自分の慢というのはもうクタクタ壊れちゃって
もう在家の人に厳しく言われちゃって
もうもう喧嘩する もう殴り合いやりたくなるぐらいのことを言われちゃって
それで自分が悪いとお釈迦様に言われると
それでやっぱり自分の人生とか性格とかね
考えることになりまして
あの性格はなくなったんですね
俺が偉いと 私は住職じゃないかと
私に先に聞くべきではないかとかね
ということはもうなくなったんですね
だからそれでやっとその人に悟りに達することができたんです
だから この自分がアピールする性格がある限りは
もう何も得られないという
だからスダッマさんがもうクタクタ
もうプライドキス もう傲慢をね
もう壊されて もう惨めに惨めに惨めになって
やっと道を発見したんですから
はい そういうことで 今日は４時までだそうですね
また何かあるみたいんですね
[背景音楽]